I think no one would argue that human
beings are fundamentally hedonistic in
other words we are wired for pleasure we
are wired to seek out experiences that
reward us neurochemical
and to shun experience that bring us
pain suffering or boredom
it is said actually that boredom can
lead to incidences of depression and
anxiety and unstimulated subjectivity is
a problem for human being now jamie
wheel says that it's a fundamental miss
wiring of our nervous system he says
that our self systems are like leaky
bucket they're like calendars no matter
how much pleasure we're getting we're
bleeding from our many holes and most of
us become bliss junkies we get hooked on
the state without ever trying to raise
this stage which is what Jamie wheel and
Steven Kotler proposed they proposed
actually transforming ourselves systems
from leaky buckets into into chalices
rides if we can render ourselves whole
and maybe render ourselves wholly this
kind of trend humanists approach to
transforming ourselves become paradise
engineers to bliss ourselves out by
transforming our fundamental wiring is
seen as heretical by the Puritan there's
a great book called after the ecstasy
the laundry which of course uses the
rationalist argument that no matter how
transcendental certain peak experiences
in our lives are to define what it's all
about carve our North Star
we should nonetheless get comfortable
with the aftereffect with the come down
after the ecstasy the laundry go back to
fetching water and chopping wood you
know I've always felt what do you do
after a mystical experience what do you
do after a cosmic orgasm what do you do
after becoming one with everything
fetching water and chopping wood and I
guess what I'm saying is that I don't
agree with that Puritan mindset of
accepting that transcendence has to be
/ arey that a fundamental wiring
requires us to come down from our bliss
and our Grace and our highs and I
propose instead something akin to David
Pierce's ideas of paradise engineering
of rewiring our hedonic set points and
actually transforming subjectivity to
engender a kind of godhood of mind
pleasures and paradises beyond anything
we can imagine so after the ecstasy more
acts
[Music]